so it's very important that we keep on
having this discussion about the
coronavirus vaccine I believe it is
super important for people to get out
there and get this thing rather you get
the moderna the Pfizer uh looks like the
Johnson Johnson today has applied for an
emergency approval so that way we can
get this one dose vaccine as quickly as
possible there's a couple more coming
down the pike but we're already seeing
in the world that this vaccine is is
working in the fight against the
coronavirus and opening back up our
country Israel has now uh decided that
they're going to vaccinate anyone over
16 and over and the reason why is
because they pretty much vaccinated
their entire adult population and still
have doses of this vaccine available so
they went ahead and opened it up for 16
and older because it's working the cases
there have plummeted rock bottom now it
is helping in our country where we are
getting more and more vaccinated every
single day when it's having a huge
effect on the numbers it's dropping our
numbers the number of hospitalizations
the number of infections the number of
deaths
but we're still not out of the woods
here
and we need to stop this anti-vax
[ __ ] people standing in front of a
goddamn Stadium where they're trying to
vaccinate a large part of the population
for their choice it's their choice to
get vaccinated
so you [ __ ] anti-backs or
anti-mask oh it's my body my choice [ __ ]
about the mask stand the [ __ ] back out
of the way
and let people who want to make the
choice to get the vaccine and help their
Community to get safe so we can open up
and get back to some sort of [ __ ]
normal here by spring or summer
get the hell out of the goddamn way and
shut your [ __ ] mouth enough is enough
of this garbage
and spread all these lies about the
vaccine how it creates other types of
diseases which is a complete [ __ ]
lunacy
and then you take one step off the
another step off the [ __ ] diving
board into this computer ship tracking
device [ __ ] that's in this goddamn
vaccine that somehow Bill Gates created
coronavirus to make sure the vaccine so
he could track you
and you're posting this [ __ ] that
there's a computer chip on Facebook
while you're on your phone with a
[ __ ] computer chip in it
this is not rocket science people you're
already being tracked the government
gives you your social security number
you have a driver's license number
you have an IP address on your phone on
your tablet on your computer and you
carry around a [ __ ] microchip every
goddamn day with your cell phone
so if you don't want to have microchips
on you and you don't want to be part of
a community where you can make it safe
throw away your cell phone go [ __ ]
live out in the Backwoods off grid would
you please and leave the rest of us
[ __ ] alone
we're trying to have civilization here
so either get vaccinated or don't but
stand the hell out of the goddamn way
and shut your [ __ ] Mouse tell you
anti-faxers [ __ ]